now let me talk a little bit about the
choices that we made in lining up the
lectures that you'll be hearing from
over the course of the semester and in
selecting the readings although some of
you have taken courses in American
international relations Theory before
none of you have taken a course exactly
like this one this is not designed to be
exhaustive it's not designed to be
comprehensive it's not designed to
provide you with an academic background
in IR theory but to give you instead
enough of a variety of perspectives on
how the world works today to provoke you
to think and to think independently and
to either form or hone your ideas and
opinions about how the world works today
what we want you to be able to do is not
memorize the positions of various
theorists but to think critically and
analytically to formulate an advocate
policy positions that are informed by
the best of modern and contemporary
social science so some of this is
garden-variety IR theory for those of
you who already had that and in fact the
readings that were signed for this week
are largely written by and about
garden-variety IR theory but much of
what we'll be reading is not that much
of it is in different fields much of it
is from different disciplines outside
political science we look at material
from all sorts of social science
disciplines from policy advocates to
various scholarly academic authors this
is designed as I suggested to make you
think and it's designed to make you
think by forcing you to engage
some of the great minds of the past and
present as they themselves struggle with
compelling international policy issues
so part of this is to have you argue
through with people who themselves are
arguing through how to understand the
world many of the readers many of the
writers that we're going to be reading
over the course of the next 13 weeks are
struggling to understand how their world
works because once they can understand
how their world works in their own
estimation they can start advocating
policy what we would call policy but
first they have to figure out what makes
this thing this world look the way it
does why are some people powerful and
other people not why are some
organizational forms privileged over
others
why do conflict seem to be endemic in
some places and not in others
how do you think about inequality how do
you think about prosperity how do you
think about fairness and equity and
justice those are the kinds of questions
that these writers are trying to
struggle with and we designed the course
assuming I think correctly that these
are the kinds of ideas that you struggle
with that you care about and we hope
that you'll learn in the course of the
term from each other as you battle the
arguments that are being made by the
people you read and the people you
listen to with each other and from the
variety of perspectives that they bring
and you bring to these issues so there
are in a sense three four different
elements to how this course works it's
who you read who you hear and who you
sit
with in class you are yourselves part of
the design of the course you bring
different experiences you bring
different perspectives you bring
different educational backgrounds work
backgrounds values things that you care
that all of those will go into the mix
as each of you tries to hone your ideas
about the way the world works
after several introductory weeks in
which you will be wrestling with reading
Western social theorists from Hobbes and
Locke to Marx and Weber this is the hard
part this is the slogging through the
dead white men part and I think that's
important and I think it's valuable and
difficult as it is because and the
reason why this this work is interesting
and important and I I urge you to take
this part seriously difficult as it is
is that when Hobbes was in Locke we're
trying to figure out how the world
worked or when Marx was trying to figure
out how the world work or when Weber was
trying to figure out how this was on the
at the beginning of the modern era in
which we live and in some respects they
were living in times of dramatic change
not dissimilar to the time we are living
in now and they were trying to figure
out a world that was changing before
their very eyes and they were trying to
figure out how it worked and what was
important and what kinds of dynamics
characterized this world so in a sense
we're going to be reading them for two
reasons one of which is they were
actually pretty smart and figuring that
out and some of what they saw resonates
through the centuries to today but also
to watch these Minds trying to figure
out how their world works because in
modest ways you want to be doing the
same thing you ought to be thinking
about what it is the
makes this place tick what's where is
power where can you get leverage for the
change you want how does the world with
new technologies with the kinds of
changes that we're seeing now how is it
going to shape your careers so you need
to be thinking to some extent in the
same way that they were thinking with
the same sorts of ambitions so think
about when you do that reading both
those things what did they say but also
how did they approach trying to figure
out their worlds but don't worry this is
not a course on the history of Western
political thought as I say we read these
ancients and they are in some respects
because they wrote at the beginning of
our own era and they wrestled with
issues we confront today including very
dramatic social political change but
then we go on to explore more
contemporary theory about things like
the causes of war and the theories that
underlie efforts to promote peaceful
dispute resolution the nature of foreign
policymaking of international efforts to
promote prosperity through trade and aid
will it be exploring the origins of the
modern state the corollary notions of
States and citizens and brights and
identities where did these things come
from
says who why are we organized this way
why do we privilege citizenship what is
citizenship anyway
so before we start advocating rights for
citizens perhaps we should know where
this idea of citizenship came from
you'll be introduced to a very small
sampling of the vast literature's about
these kinds of questions some of it the
conventional wisdom some of it very
critical all of this is designed the
emphasis on critical analysis on
articulate and informed advocacy is
designed to make you better at what
you're going to do and that brings me to
one of the most important of the general
points I
today and that is that all public policy
is based on a theory or several theories
sometimes the policymaker knows the
assumptions that he or she is making and
sometimes he or she is not that self
conscious but all policymakers all
people have assumptions about how the
world works all people have theories
that help them organize the facts which
is salt them daily all of you have
theories with which you organize your
interactions with each other your
assumptions about how it classful were
your assumptions about how a school
operates not to say the Lord your world
that you are intending to pursue
professional careers in you all have
beliefs about what motivates human
behavior about what causes conflict
about how we should measure value about
what the rights of citizens should be
about how identities are formed and many
other things you have beliefs about
those we could poll you now and everyone
here has an opinion a theory about these
questions but the chances are pretty
good that you don't actually know where
these ideas come from or what
alternatives that might be even within
this room so I may have a view about how
to measure value but there are probably
dozens of other views in this very room
not to say in the world as a whole about
that about how we might do that we
collectively at seeker believe that
public policies are made better by
people who recognize their assumptions
that is know where what those theories
are acknowledge their theoretical
predispositions and and most importantly
embrace their normative implications
that means you have theories about how
the world works and on the basis of
those theories
you also have preferences about how the
world should work that says it should be
and we want you to be more self aware
more self conscious about both your
theories and your preferences we happen
to think as you can well imagine that
Columbia is a particularly good place to
do that because it's a great research
university and you have access to some
of the world's most distinguished
academic theorists of international
affairs some of whom will be arrayed
before you over the course of the
semester so that in addition to the
skills and knowledge you'll get in other
courses here you will be exposed to
analytical perspectives that should make
you a more sophisticated and more
confident policymaker and you'll be able
to recognize what it means when somebody
says that something is a liberal
theorist or a realist theorist and no
and this is important it makes the
reading much easier when you realize
this much of the language we use is
jargon technical uses of everyday words
so when we say realist or we say
rational or we say efficient we don't
necessarily mean what you would mean by
those words if you are talking to your
uncle at the dinner table these are
technically use them in technical ways
and part of what we're going to be doing
over the semester is making sure that
you understand that vocabulary it's not
magic it's not mysterious but it makes
everything much clearer once you do
understand that vocabulary so we'll ask
why policymakers advocate democratic
politics is it is there a theory behind
democracy that is desirable or why they
celebrate or abhor globalization or why
they predict war in certain
circumstances what they mean by the
terms what they expect by those
phenomena and and most importantly and
this is one of the reasons why we want
you to participate in your section do
you agree with them when you hear a
policymaker advocate a particular
position do you agree and if you do why
and if you don't why not by the time
you're finished with your time at c5 if
not by the time you're finished with
this semester you ought to be able to
answer that question as I suggested most
policymakers particularly in this day
and age are reasonably well aware of
what their theories are and who else
shares them but keep in mind that that's
actually in the larger scheme of human
history relatively new for many many was
what we would call policymakers over the
course of human history rulers of
various kinds they learned the theories
of that human nature and about what was
right and wrong and so forth and so on
more from their families than from any
formal education increasingly
policymakers reflect a formal education
like the one that you're embarking on
now and in fact both kinds of education
both kinds of backgrounds are visible on
the world stage today there are some
people in fact many people whose policy
prescriptions whose vocabulary whose
view of the world whose understanding of
how the world works reflect exactly the
same kind of formal education that
you've been lucky to have so far and are
going to continue over the course of the
next two years but there are a few
people and I will give you an example
for whom that is not the case Muammar
Gaddafi in Libya is a very acute
psychologist in the world in which he
was raised a world of tribal identities
where kinship Trump's bureaucratic
and we're reciprocity and border are as
powerful as any stock market the
underlying theories of human nature
about markets about the character of
prosperity about morality and
responsibility and about government that
come out of that world are in full view
in his manifesto the Green Book
so should you want to see an example of
political theory born of an experience
that is complete virtual II completely
bereft of formal education in a policy
school you can look at it at his green
book for him and still for some other
world figures and for many many ordinary
people in the world today and I think
you need to recall that globalization
whatever we mean by that but whatever
the consensus about globalization is it
represents a bizarre and alien
phenomenon bringing in its wake a
complicated jumble of the tempting and
the odious at the other end of the
spectrum are people like and I choose
these for object or reasons that will
become apparent former Secretary of
State Madeleine Albright a very well
educated policymaker
or for that matter the ex-president of
Tanzania
also a very well educated policymaker
both of them did graduate work at
Columbia even if they are not always and
completely self-conscious about the
theoretical foundations of their
policies the marginal utility theory of
value that underlines capitalist
economics the liberal consumption of
human nature that encourages supportive
democratization around the world their
grasp of the complexity of globalization
however they ultimately assess it
reflects familiarity with ideas that
animate it they're privileged by the
ascendancy of the assumptions in
globalization that are familial familiar
and can
so there is a privilege in the world
today for people who are familiar with
its language understand these kinds of
ideas are educated in its terms as you
are if you will permit me to remind you
anyone who got into this room is among
the privileged not only materially but
intellectually you who are here already
even before you finish this course are
among the intellectual and policy leader
of the world you no more see further and
have more responsibility than the vast
part of humanity now or ever and among
your responsibilities it seems to me or
self consciousness and awareness of the
limits of your knowledge empathy for
those who see the world differently and
willingness to engage in constructive
criticism that's what this course is
designed to encourage you to do now a
little about the readings the readings
are for those of you who have surveyed
the syllabus very heavily weighted
toward American Theory American authors
American policymakers are vastly
over-represented in this syllabus now we
could assign Gaddafi's green book it's
certainly assigned in universities in
Libya but the assignments in this course
are largely from the Western Canon and
current American academic scholarship
and policy analysis that's partly
because you've chosen to come to an
American University you could have gone
to school in Libya and the curriculum
will reflect where we are as I think it
should but it's also partly let's be
candid about this American hegemony is
not only political but intellectual as
well you aren't in Libya for a reason
Americans produce a disproportionate
amount of
rationalization of the world system from
which they disproportionately profit now
whether this is right or not is part of
what I hope will animate your
discussions for the next semester this
is for us all to debate and for you
individually to decide but I think it's
part of why we design of course the way
we do it's to give you that cannon some
critical perspectives on it and then to
let you to require you to debate that
with each other and in - and with
yourself this Court should give you an
opportunity to examine your own
assumptions to strengthen your own
self-consciousness about the theoretical
traditions your policy positions reflect
and to make you therefore a more acute
analyst and advocate the readings for
this week are designed to do several
things to outline a variety of the
perspectives on international relations
in American academic and policy circles
today these are representative and if
any of you have taken an IR course these
will be familiar to you they're
certainly not exhaustive but they give
you as good a taste as you need they're
also designed to encourage you to read
analytically need to begin to
distinguish between normative argument
how things should be and descriptive or
empirical argument how things are those
two are very different and they're often
conflated and the more you can
distinguish as you read as you argue as
you write yourself between description
and normative argument the stronger your
description will be and the stronger
your advocacy will be they're also
designed to encourage you to read
critically fine finding points who agree
with
and disagree with and then thinking
about what the implications of agreeing
with this particular argument might be
for other arguments that are related to
it as I suggest that people have
theories about human nature a couple of
years ago an American neoconservative
writer characterized the difference
between political tendencies in the
United States in the following way
liberals believed in the peaceful and
cooperative nature of mankind when
confronted with aggression and violence
they tend to assume it is motivated by
just cause such as socio-economic
deprivation or exploitation by
foreigners let's innocently
conservatives know that evil lurks in
men's hearts
so just for starters you might consider
whether you think human nature can be
characterized in terms of immutable
characteristics like good and evil quite
a lot of how you understand policy in
general and Foreign Affairs in
particular may write on that if you
think there is good and evil in the
world you will very likely take policy
positions that are somewhat different
from those who think that there is
actually not really good and evil there
are circumstances which impel people
debate in certain ways so you should
think about those kinds of questions if
you were to take an International
Relations course anywhere in the United
States today debates within and among
the three schools of thought that are
described in the readings realist
liberal and idealist or constructivist
would be the principal content of the
course now keep in mind as I suggested
before that this is technical language
liberal or liberals are not necessarily
unrealistic people nor are realists
without ideals but these are labels for
particular ways of understanding how the
world
works realists like Henry Kissinger for
example or perhaps in the early days
Condoleezza Rice look at International
Relations is comprised of states
competing to survive in a lawless world
oh sure there's international law but it
doesn't really determine how states
interact with each other
say the realists the competition uses
war and threats of war to prevent other
states from a granting power at the
expense of the state in question for
realists in other words there are in the
unit of analysis as the state and the
states are competing with each other
ir is sometimes International Relations
is sometimes called a game of Nations as
States try to predict each other's moves
balance against or Ally with more
powerful States maintain their own
position or the stability of the system
although realists need not see the world
in terms of good and evil in fact I
would argue that most do not they do
share a predisposition to see the world
as a struggle among essentially
immutable competitors liberals by
contrast and it is a pretty remarkable
contrast although many people slide into
shades of grey there are pure realists
and pure liberals if you will like Mel
and Albright or Tony Blair see States
interacting on many more grounds than
merely survival in Anarchy and those
other grounds things like economic links
Norman over ideological commonalities
the transatlantic alliance a common
interest in prosperity or a commitment
to democratic values these all mitigate
conflict and promote cooperation say the
Liberals
so that they'll start with states in the
same way that the realists do but then
they'll say but there are other kinds of
relationships not just relationships of
competition that will shape how the
state center
with each other some liberals some
liberals actually see some of these
other dynamics economic or normative
relations for example as equally perhaps
more important than the state and
providing an explanatory variable in X
providing an explanation of how the
world is working and they hold out the
possibility of change so liberals are
much more inclined to see mutability in
the system that there is particularly
not only a possibility of change but
they tend to be optimistic this change
is for the better so you have to think
to yourself of whether you think that's
plausible or not constructivists of whom
there has been no Secretary of State yet
although read the article by Robert
Jervis carefully Condoleezza Rice in her
latter years might qualify but
constructivists may be represented for
example by Kofi Annan at his tenure at
the United Nations where state behavior
was seen more and more as shaped by
prevailing definitions of the state and
state sovereignty and power among other
things neither the state nor the citizen
is natural the default condition of
humankind nor necessarily the building
block of international society and both
realists and liberals would argue that
those are the building blocks of
international society differing as they
do on what that societies like and what
the dynamics of that society is the
constructivist would argue not
necessarily perhaps now but not always
John Ruggie special advisor to Kofi
Annan and one-time dean of the School of
International public affairs at Columbia
advocated for the UN's new global
compact by arguing and I quote we need
to devise a broadly acceptable concept
of corporate citizenship in the global
community
arguing in other words that the private
sector was becoming more important in
this international
society and that corporations were
becoming if not as important as state
certainly important players like States
if we can devise new concepts if we can
introduce new players into this game of
Nations then it is a very beautiful
system it's not just that things can get
better but things can change completely
the name of the game the players of the
game
everything can be altered whether it's
calling it a war on terror or calling a
corporate citizenship the world is a
very malleable place now most
conventional international relations
theorists in the United States are born
of the realist tradition and you will be
reading several summaries or overviews
of these schools of thought by people
who would describe themselves as
essentially realists dismissing the
radical country critiques as having been
shown wanting with the collapse of the
Soviet Union and quick to conclude that
realism or sometimes neo realism still
despite the changes in the world over
the last decade or so reigns supreme in
these assessments they as I suggested
reflect the American academic
establishment consensus a consensus
that's still profoundly shaped by the
Cold War keep in mind that virtually all
of the theorists working in these
paradigms just about everyone making
policy today was brought up in train
during the Cold War so the their
experience is vastly different from
yours and one of the things that you
should think about is the extent to
which there is continuing to be in this
literature that you're going to
reading the contemporary literature and
overhang of the Cold War yes yes as
Robert Pervis suggests perhaps the Bush
administration's policy and the debates
that have raged around it reflect
genuinely novel genuinely post Cold War
schools of thought for whatever else we
may think of the Bush administration
policy it may have been unmoored from
the Cold War Bush's aspiration to as
gervais puts it remake the system not in
the hegemon that is in the american
interest but in the hegemon image is a
new way of conceptualizing the rights
and responsibilities of the world's
great power by realist standards this is
not only quite mutable but once we have
decided that the image is as important
as the interest we're moving toward a
constructivist position now this clearly
in some respects has echoes of the past
it borrows from imperialism as pfaff and
others have pointed out in its
civilizing mission and from the
conservatives who divided the world into
good and evil but from the liberal
conviction that democracy promotes peace
and from the constructive principle that
at least among the good the world is as
we make it
it borrows from very very disparate
contemporary perspectives
so while tyrannies may be immutably evil
as far as the Bush administration policy
has gone change for the better is
nonetheless possible in the promotion of
democracy and that in turn is not merely
the prerogative but the responsibility
of world leadership both its but because
it is in the interest of the world's
head hegemon that is the United States
but because it is morally right by
American lights so these arguments the
pro and con of the Bush administration
policy our variance of and build upon
underlying debate so that the character
not only of the world order the
relations among states the primacy of
states and so forth but about human
nature itself about whether you think
human beings are driven by an
unchangeable good or evil quality or
whether they are mutable next week we're
going to be turning to the origins of
some of these ideas in Western political
theory as we leap into some of the most
difficult reading of the semester in the
meantime however I hope that you will
enjoy debating these kinds of questions
in your section readings and with that I
will stop and take any questions that
there are and then we can move on thank
you